on crews Eddie Murphy Kevin Bacon
they all became superstars in the 1980s
but here at ET we're celebrating our
35th season so we were right there
behind the scenes of the biggest films
of the decade do you like a little bit
of danger yeah sure
I enjoy excitement yeah I guess I've
only been like three movies so if the
body would fall out in my career I'd do
a TV series it's been a growth period
and a strengthening period for me but
like you said there is no mobile home
with a try speed air condition to go
back to it oh the 80s how we'd love you
it's back when the big stars now we're
just becoming famous iconic movie scenes
were just being shot and this guy just
felt the need when girls bombard you in
your room in a crazed Tom
a crazed Tom Cruise that kind of stuff
is a little uncomfortable yeah he had
that Tom Cruise laughs even back then
and on the set there were some more
recognizable faces including Val Kilmer
in this graduation seemed graduations
thank you there's only one degree of
separation between Tom and mr. Footloose
himself Kevin Bacon I'm 24 years old and
I came to New York when I was 17 I'm not
a newcomer here's a cool onset secret we
discovered they shot this scene to the
classic a Johnny be good but in the
movie it was replaced with the film's
theme song
and we met another movie rookie that day
Sarah Jessica Parker I've never done a
film before I'm learning more and I'm
watching more when you have a dance
partner like Kevin Bacon you can't go
wrong two years later we found escapees
future husband Matthew Broderick riding
a float in downtown Chicago and lip
syncing to the Beatles that came
naturally to me to play somebody playing
hooky I did skip school a bit quite a
bit I'm in this very Park actually other
80s movie sets we visited Flashdance
with Jennifer Beals Robin Williams was
our tour guide on good morning Vietnam
I've been finding the seats like having
sex in the winter and who could forget
the movie that made everybody think
differently about cheating elevator sex
and bunny her mom Scarah morning 1 for 2
hours the action comedy
I like those type of type of films in
1984 Eddie Murphy dropped a little bet
you didn't know this movie trivia on the
set of Beverly Hills Cop character was
really written for white guy so we're a
little soul brother to it two years
later we were with Charlie and Johnny
Sheen was 20
Jeff was 22 when we made the trek to the
Philippines to witness the Best Picture
Oscar winner platoon being made take it
easy Crawford the stories told through
my eyes which is kind of a heavy
responsibility but an excellent
opportunity as an actor but come on we
definitely got to get props for this PT
on the set of E T Spielberg and a cool
retro Raiders of the Lost Ark trucker
hat did you guys wear your bicycles just
right from the camera we watched the
master himself at work as he shot the
scene that happened right before this
another director we love is Ron Howard
we got him on the set of parenthood it
was 1989 our show was just eight years
old but we already had a milestone Wow
Entertainment Tonight 2000 episodes well
I guess that sort of makes sense I've
probably seen about 1200 and now in our
35th year we are up to episode number
8922
keep up the good work I love the show